nous allons reparler de l'afghanistan
puisque nous recevons maintenant latif
hauteur de visage volet avoir 20 ans à
kaboul s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
latifa bonsoir chebbi bonsoir vous avez
traduire oui oui vous êtes la présidente
de l'association afghanistan libre et je
dois dire que noël mamère est un des
seuls hommes politiques en france à
avoir été présent la manifestation en
faveur des femmes afghanes le 29
septembre dernier voilà alors donc
latifa publie chez anne carrière un
livre qui s'appelle visage volet avoir
20 ans à kaboul qui raconte la vie avant
et après le pouvoir des talibans
interview vérité
oui
latifa vous êtes né dans une famille
aisée de kaboul votre mère était
gynécologue votre père était dans
l'import export et vous est la dernière
de cinq enfants vous êtes né en 1981 ce
qui veut dire que vous n'avez connu que
la guerre rend visite à force de vivre
dans la guerre
nous étions devenus indifférents à la
tragédie de notre pays nous étions
anesthésiés au point de ne pas voir
arriver
l'ultime menace des talibans c'est à
dire que derrière cette guerre il y
avait quelque chose d'encore plus graves
qui arrivait alors jusqu'à l'âge de
saison et malgré le fait que votre pays
soit dans la guerre vous avez une vie
assez insouciante d'une certaine façon
surprenante
à l'âge de 16 ans j'avais une
adolescence associant tu j'étais à
quelques mois de passer mon bac à
l'orias j'avais des amis garçons filles
et surtout j'étais mal je m'étais
inscrite à la faculté de journalistes
pour devenir journaliste oui c'est vrai
qu'avant l'arrivée des talibans vous
participiez à des rencontres sportives
ou des rencontres culturelles
vous parlez de mode avec vos amis vous
allez au cinéma vous voulez devenir
journaliste
si tu te fais partie de ce que vous êtes
partie de ma vie avant mes 16 ans et en
parler de mode avec les avis sur tout on
écoutait beaucoup de musique la musique
c'était très important pour nous voilà
et pendant ce temps là avec l'aide des
américains avec l'aide des usa
le pakistan venait en aide à la mise en
place des talibans
cammas l'année chez sony canada
sur cette mode adorent les statues en
bois les nazis que marlon afro de big
one à la date à laquelle à mon idole dj
avant l'arrivée des deux erreurs je
m'intéressais pas beaucoup à la
politique je dois le dire ça me dépasse
un petit peu je m'intéressais pas mais
voir ces étrangers dans mon pays ça m'a
permis de m'intéresser un peu plus à la
géopolitique et de voir ces étrangers
sur notre sol est voir d'où il venait et
ça ça fait encore plus mal effectivement
alors le 27 septembre
1996 les talibans entre dans le cadre
houle
les écoles sont fermées les femmes sont
humiliés insultés
enfermé est obligé de porter ce que vous
portez ce soir c'est à dire le tchadri
sharakova comme l'asie qu'est
la guinée a connu pour 27 septembre
c'est vrai que c'était le jour qu'il a
basculé l'avis de toutes les femmes à
caveau toutes les jeunes filles et cette
ville est devenue une ville en deuil
et moi j'étais plus là latifa de la
veille et j'ai changé un jour
effectivement comme toutes les jeunes
filles 27 septembre 96 alors ces
talibans sont pas tous afghans ni même
tous patchoune il ya des pakistanais il
ya des arabes ils ont une chose en
commun c'est d'être barbu et d'avoir une
barbe qui va mesurer la longueur de la
main
sur tout ce qu' ils ont aussi c'est un
regard atroce c'est affreux qui valorise
le qui vous glacent le sang seul instant
il suffit de croiser ce regard et je
peux vous dire que vous l'oubliez plus
jamais la première chose qui vous étonne
vraiment c'est que les talibans exhibe
la dépouille de l'ex président najib ou
là qui a été lynché avant d'être pendu
et vous le voyez avec des cigarettes
enfoncé dans la bouche et des billes qui
dépasse de ses poches et pour vous c'est
un spectacle ignoble
la chasse
était encore plus ignoble de voir ça et
surtout la sauvagerie des talibans
puisque le dr n'est du goût là qu'était
le président était un pachtoune et qu'il
pensait qu'avec les talibans ils
allaient tous trouvé un allié et le voir
pendu dès le premier jour ça nous a
montré à quel point ils sont capables du
pire c'est talbot et puis viennent les
consignes des talibans les décrets
respecter l'avalanche des interdits les
filles et les femmes n'ont plus le droit
de travailler à l'extérieur
les lois commencé à venir vers lui après
les autres pas seulement pour les femmes
mais aussi pour les hommes parce que le
sort des hommes étaient payés pas mieux
non plus parce que toute
l'administration a été fermée donc les
hommes non plus n'avait pas le droit de
travailler puisque aucune administration
nous fonctionner à part le ministère de
la promotion de la vertu et on this way
alors les femmes ne peuvent plus sortir
sans être revêtue du tchad riz et sans
être accompagnées d'un homme
charmant
alors imaginez le char de toutes ces
veuves qui depuis 18 années de guerre
parce qu'avant les talibans y avait dix
huit années de guerre qui n'avaient pas
d'homme et qui n'est pas de mari ou pas
de frère avait perdu imaginer le sort de
ces femmes à quel point elle se faisait
humilier
à
toutes ces femmes qui pour exister dans
la rue simple pour faire une simple
course a besoin d'une présence masculine
y en avait pas dans les familles de
kaboul n'est pas dans toutes les
familles de 13 ans masculins alors fini
de maquillage fini le rouge à lèvres
fini le vernis à ongles et si on porte
du vernis à ongles on peut avoir les
doigts coupés
c'était un dd des histoires rapportées
par une de mes amies proches j'ai rêvé
vu justement les doigts coupés de cette
femme et moi je vous raconte
l'anecdote delà de cette femme avec ses
chaussures blanches
mais la première fois que je suis sorti
dans la rue ce qui m'a décidé de ne plus
sortir dans la partir de ce jour là
c'était de rencontrer cette femme dans
la rue qui se faisait frapper parce que
c'est fou est rempli de plomb au pied
parce qu'elle portait des chaussures
blanches qui était la même couleur que
la couleur des drapeaux les talibans et
qu'il fallait que ça devienne rouge
comme c'est comme avec la couleur de
sens où
aucun médecin
homme ne doit toucher le corps d'une
femme et comme les femmes ne peuvent
plus travailler elles ne sont plus
soignés donc elle meurt
médecins ne pouvaient toucher les femmes
et
moi même c'était juste un exemple pour
me faire soigner j'ai dit j'ai dû
quitter kaboul pour partir à peshawar au
pakistan pour me faire soigner parce que
le médecin n'avait pas le droit de me
touche et me soigner interdit d'écouter
de la musique interdit de faire des
photos
musiques robbery and the do la série
jason à matane voilà la musique était
interdite dès le début ce qui nous a le
plus touché nous les jeunes parce que ça
faisait partie de notre vie quotidienne
mais malgré ça on avait quand même notre
résistance était d'écouter de la musique
clandestine et donc d'avoir des
cassettes étaient à l'intérieur de la
maison la peur au ventre en écouter
quand même la musique dans les non
musulmans sont obligés de revêtir des
vêtements jaune ce qui rappelle ici de
bons souvenirs interdit de vendre des
sous vêtements féminins
et comme un des objets profane est alors
le plus étonnant pourquoi interdit de
sifflets et de posséder des bouilloires
sifflante
ça rappelait les sons musicaux et ça
rappelle pour eux c'est hélas la voie du
satin
interdit de posséder des chiens ou des
oiseaux et vous êtes obligé de dire
adieu à votre chien bingo
non seulement j'ai en ai dû se séparer
de nos animaux mais sachez que le sort
de beaucoup d'entre nous étaient bien
pires que ces animaux dont on était
obligé de se séparer voilà et puis à le
tchadri donc avant les talibans quand
vous voyez des femmes revêtues du
tchadri vous les ateliers les les
bouteilles vous les ateliers les choux
fleurs à l'envers vous appeliez les sacs
à provisions
je pense qu'on se moquait de ces femmes
ces pauvres femmes avec mes amis pas
seulement moi mais mes amis jamais on
était loin de se douter qu'un jour on
serait nous mêmes des choux fleurs alors
au début vous restez chez vous et puis
voulait pas sortir vêtus du tchad riz à
kaboul et puis un jour devant
l'insistance d'une amie vous essayez
vous dites ce n'est pas un vêtement
c'est une prison
d'osio de retard et a pronostiqué temps
correct il est certes pas
la seule je discutais qu'aux jeunes
filles beaucoup de jeunes filles pas les
femmes nous agit mais surtout les jeunes
filles il faut vraiment qu'on attend
d'une excuse pour se faire soigner ou
une vraie excuse pour sortir de la
maison parce qu'on se dit sortir d'une
prison dans une autre au moins dans la
nôtre à l'intérieur on n'est pas obligé
de venir nous frapper humilie alors
qu'avec notre prison le tchadri on n'est
pas l'abri de l'humiliation quatre mois
donc après l'arrivée des talibans vous
sortez enfin
et vous dites pourtant ce qui prouve
votre état d'esprit vous dites si mon
futur mari me demandait de porter un
foulard ou un tchador hors de la maison
j'accepterai son problème
i tunes marché mais
déjà le tchad heures quand je faisais ma
prière dans mon coin donc effectivement
je suis une musulmane est croyante
pratiquante mais nous devons partager le
même point de vue et savoir pourquoi je
le porte et pour rien au monde je
perdrais aucune autre de mes libertés
et puis elle est violent un jour trois
jeunes filles arrivent chez vous pour
être soigné par votre mère d'une façon
clandestine et vous découvrez à ce
moment là qu'elles ont été victimes non
seulement de viols et de mutilations
illégal jeune arrière de boue de cadre
aux légumes à feuilles des lycéens à
bout de
sa main jackass asie est nommé connaître
aux hommes étaient effectivement qu'on
était capable qu'on pouvait un être
humain ne pouvait être capable de
traiter avec autant de violence et de
haine une femme c'est quelque chose je
vous assure qu'ils étaient inimaginables
tant qu'on ne voit pas exception peut
pas imaginer qu'un homme peut faire
autant de mal à une femme gratuite
pendant ce temps
le ministre de la santé des talibans est
reçu à paris dans le pays des droits de
l'homme et quand vous apprenez ça quelle
est votre réaction à motonat ma rose à
gauche ou au charbon des galettes à la
fraude
youtube ou d'amis un beau djibouti comme
à la radio que l'on détient à cette
époque là donc c'était notre seule
occupation aussi dépassé cette radio de
chercher les informations je ne raconte
pas la tristesse des gens à kaboul de
voir cette propagande faite par les
talibans
ou de voir ce représentant le terreau
manqué qu'un reçu dans un pays européen
qui plus est les pays de la démocratie
des droits de l'homme je peux vous dire
qu'ils ont fait de la propagande pour
nous dire qu'ils ont été reconnus ici
et là vous quitter l'afghanistan avec
votre père votre mère et une amie une
fatwa est lancé contre vous est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez peur de cette
fatwa
brigades abu darda
léger moins peur pour moi
mais pour moi j'ai plus peur pour toutes
ces femmes qui m'ont choisie pour venir
porter leur message ici et qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui la balle est donc aucune
nouvelle je sais pas ce qu'elle devienne
c'est pour elle que j'ai plus peur parce
que c'est elle qui sont en danger
latifa
aujourd'hui des gens en france vous
regardez gens à l'étranger vous regarde
dans beaucoup de pays du monde
qu'avez vous à dire aux gens qui vous
regardent
la mer
johnny
à ouallam à brax sonacotra exane a avoué
entre de surebet amer que ça me prends
moi je suis un chien dès lors dire que
jusqu'à jusqu'à quand ce silence et
cette indifférence contre la faim de
magna qui aujourd'hui souffrent les
bains aurait rien à attendre de ce tabac
tue au nom ça ça tu as tu as marqué trop
de temps à sa gamme phare dos à la miga
chawi en compte dans la mare en moi je
vais signer pour la famille organes
c'est une femme aussi comme n'importe
quelle femme dans le monde si un jour ce
sort vous touche ça m'étonnerait que
vous acceptiez ce soir là et je pense
que vous serez bien content deux camps
soient toutes les femmes dans le monde
bienvenue dans votre vie vous aider
va
laisser
ça fait longtemps ça fait trop longtemps
aujourd'hui l'afghanistan et les
errements sur tous les tableaux ont
besoin qu'on pense que blessures
si quelqu'un vous poser des questions à
latifa noël elisabeth philippe orlando
titom ccc absolument terrifiant et moi
je dire on ne peut que
vous exprimer notre respect et notre
solidarité vous demandez ce que nous
pouvons faire nous citoyens pour vous
pour vous aider
d'accord je vais maintenant besoin
d'éducation c'est la base même de ce
dont nous voulons aujourd'hui en
afghanistan aidez nous à voir la paix
dans notre pays puisque seulement
construire déjà
aujourd'hui vous avez nous avons
désormais très bien décédé depuis des
années déjà vous pouvez aider ces zones
là c'est aussi un combat comme un autre
ils ont déposé des questions et latifa
d'abord je ne comprends pas comment vous
avez pu en arriver là c'est une question
cruel peut-être mais la femme toujours
eu au sein de la société un pouvoir même
si c'était un pouvoir cacher il ya un
pouvoir sur les sur les maris au pouvoir
sur les frais rien le pouvoir sur les
ficelles donne la vie donc on est quand
même l'intermédiaire absolument
indispensable d'une société comment se
peut-il que c'est un tel pouvoir qui est
qui et lanteri nation de la lutte entre
les sexes au dans le sens les plus
barbares puisse être installé voilà ma
question je comprends pas je ne
comprends pas
je m'envole vila-matas la jungle avec m
rose john mcconnell elle complète
aliments sont arrivés au pouvoir en
afghanistan il y avait déjà des huit
années de guerre derrière ce peuple donc
il y avait déjà dix huit années de
guerre derrière ce peuple donc le peuple
était détruit avec l'invasion soviétique
et quand ils sont arrivés il y avait
déjà un peuple détruits et les talibans
pour la plupart sont des jeunes prélever
tout tout petit et qui sont élevés dans
des madrassas en dehors de tout amour
maternel au nord de toute présence
et qui ne savent absolument pas ce que
veut dire l'amour et la chaleur d'une
famille donc forcément c'est là où l'on
fabrique cette
excuse sont pas des talibans ne se sont
pas révoltés contre cet état de fait
parce quand même ce sont leurs femmes et
il les vend des femmes les hommes et les
femmes se révoltent tous les jours
contre les talibans et ne serait-ce qu'
on est quand même aujourd'hui au bout de
cinq semaines une armée comme l'armée
américaine n'arrive pas à toucher les
talibans nous ça fait sept ans qu'on se
bat contre les taliban et contre le
terrorisme et nous avons quand même des
zones libres où il ya 5 millions de
personnes qui habitent on continue à
construire des écoles des hôpitaux et à
donner du travail aux femmes et ça veut
bien dire qu'on a réussi là où
aujourd'hui il est plus grande armée du
monde échoue et alors que je suis vous
l'expliquer aux centaines d hommes
talibans vis-à-vis des femmes parce que
s'ils détruisent toutes les femmes
comment ils vont se procurer comment ils
vont y rester je ne sais pas c'est pas
du tout c'est une machination de l'état
dément ce n'est pas qui se tenait
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont reçus par le
quai d'orsay ce sont aussi les arabes
l'arabie saoudite et les émirats puisque
c'est les trois pays qui reconnaissent
le régime des talibans où ils ont leurs
ambassades aujourd'hui et le but c'est
pas de prendre le laissez pas de
procréer ou quoi que ce soit le but
c'est de reprendre le territoire afghan
donc le meilleur façon de détruire une
nation se détruire sa femme donc par la
destruction de la femme afghane ont
détruit la nation afghane et on a le
territoire libre d'afghanistan qui est
quand même l'objet de convoitises depuis
des centaines et des milliers d'années
dernière question
les français se demandent ce qu'il faut
faire et se demandent s'il faut soutenir
les américains et se demande s'il ya
d'autres moyens d'action vous qui êtes
afghane et qui militait pour un
afghanistan libre et démocratique que
nous conseillez-vous
c'est très simple il faut déjà une
pression il faut arrêter de
2,2 jouer avec les gens en recevant
celui dont les avants demande
aujourd'hui qu'il soit devant le
tribunal international c'est le pakistan
et le prise d'un mouchard f aujourd'hui
il est reçu comme un de nos meilleurs
amis comme c'était le cas il ya quelques
mois pour les talibans donc ça c'est
insupportable pour les avants ça peut
pas passer alors que les afghans en
afghanistan la semaine dernière me
demander tu vas faire quelque chose
là-bas pour leur dire qu'il faut mettre
le pakistan tente devant le tribunal
international
aujourd'hui il est ici au quai d'orsay
donc je me sens un peu faible et de
l'autre côté il y a des il faut faire de
l'humanitaire dans les zones où les gens
sont en train de mourir avec le froid
qui approche dans les zones où souvent
c'est fait c'est pas très facile d'accès
pour les ong donc il faut y aller mais
surtout il faut aider les olives dans
les projets de développement il faut
faire en sorte que ces gens continuent
dans leur élan d'espoir et qui
continuent à être opérationnel le jour
où le pays libre ces femmes continuent à
être opérationnel au jour aux puces au
pays et libre je suis allé dans un camp
de réfugiés une femme qui me regarde
dans les yeux me dit j'ai perdu mon mari
mon frère mais tu pourras faire quelque
chose pour la petite pour que la et à
l'école donc ça veut dire qu'elle elle
continue à croire louis si on n'a pas le
droit de les abonnés que dire qu'il faut
soutenir les américains alors parce
qu'ils sont le blur leur but c'est de
c'est ça que je pose la question pose la
question puisque leur but c'est de
détruire les talibans alors faut-il
soutenir les américains quelle est
l'opinion d'une afghane je pense que le
pilote d'une afghane et des avancées que
l'europe puisse enfin trouver une
identité et que ne suivent pas les
américains aveuglément etc les avants
qu'ils attendent beaucoup plus des
européens et des français aujourd'hui
depuis toujours un à dix les français
ont idéalisé massoud et tout le monde
pense que la france a beaucoup aidé et
m'a soutenu ce qu'est pas ce qui n'est
pas le cas ce qui est pas vrai comme
vous avez très bien dit monsieur mamère
dans un article que trois mois après sa
réception ici rien n'avait bougé pour
l'alliance donc on l'a dit pendant des
années a été victime de notre grand
amour avec la france mais c'est pas pour
autant que la france nous a aidés merci
et
eh ben dis donc voilà donc c'était le
témoignage de latifa et c'est un petit
peu finalement
grâce à la télévision comme si pendant
la guerre on avait vu des gens
qui seraient sortis d'un camp de
concentration
pour venir témoigner la télévision donc
là on peut pas dire qu'on savait pas
puisque on sait voilà c'est que la
grande différence avec ce qui s'est
passé entre 1942 et 1945 voilà et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux